Russia is a part of international
community and responsible part of
international community taking care
about the peace and prosperity in the
world and I hope Russia will continue it
more of course we need more cooperation
and better understanding between Russia
and its neighbors and partners like
United States for example I hope that we
will see improvements and be later the
relationships between United States and
Russia do you think when Donald Trump
becomes president that relations between
Russia and the US will improve it's
difficult to say of course but we hope I
think it give us chance to find more
constructive dialogue because I think
that it will give us chance to go back
to fundamentals I think that
fundamentally we have much more in
common much more joint interests between
the United States and Russia than
controversies and we need more
cooperation between Russia in the United
States to address global issues like
terrorism global warming so on and so
forth and I hope that we will see
progress on this so you're are you
optimistic that the United States who
drop its sanctions against Russia once
mr. Trump becomes president it's
difficult to church and it's a political
topic beyond of my expertise but I hope
that we will see a better relationships
and as a result unwinding of sanctions
I'm not about the relationship between
the United Kingdom and Russia obviously
it's gone through a fairly troubled
period in recent years do you see any
optimism there difficult to say but I'm
sure that like in the case with the
United States we have much more common
interests with UK to address global
issues that they address bellator of
issues and I hope that we will see more
constructive dialogues and we've got
recently and with all changes in
political landscape economic landscape
you'll see more and more cut rationed
but I hope that we see more
consciousness in the world about the
problems and I hope that politicians
will demonstrate no understanding of
necessity to cooperate to address these
issues also issues of inequality issues
of globalization which made our people
not happy and
for to address it we need to address
global issues we need global solutions
and I'm sure that Russia and Yuki could
and should be a part of the solution do
you feel that globalization is under
attack at the moment I mean that was
something that seeing ping spoke about
yesterday
Davos is that on your mind globalization
became everyday reality of our life and
if you speak about quality of goods
which we consume quality of services
which we consume about the quality of
life freedom of travel and so on and so
forth
we can't avoid globalization but we have
to make results of globalization more
[Music]
palatable
[Music]
we have to make this is also
globalization also attractive for all
people in our societies it needs a major
challenge I don't think we are talking
about the decline of globalization I
seen that globalization will continue as
a part of competitiveness of basically
everybody in this world but we have to
make it more effective and if he speak
about globalization and the current
economical situation I do believe that
we should not officially suspend
globalization or competition but we
should find the way to help those who
didn't benefit enough from it and help
them to find the very new society in new
economy but not to undermine the
economic perspective of the whole world
so dimensions of globalization and
competition now you teach your MBA
qualification here in the UK how do you
assess the UK's prospects outside the EU
UK is a strong country having a lot of
smart people and strong economy and I
think that inspired current rhetoric
relationships economic relationships
between United Kingdom and Europe
contingent on Europe are far greater
than many people believe and it will
impedes from exceeds people from
extremes I hope and I hope that because
of these genuine economic relationships
UK and contingent on Europe we'll find
the way to deal together and find that a
good way for brexit because it's not in
anybody interest to hurt either Europe
or UK even a 19% stake in the tour
operator cheery there's been speculation
that you'd like to increase that to as
much as 25% what's your thinking behind
that I think that fundamentally - is
well positioned to benefit from the
growth of global economy and growth of
tourism sector I think that demand for
travel is genuine for people and it
gives a good chance for good player in
this industry and tui is the best I
believe to benefit from it and I hope
that two of them grow